turning to run rich run is what we got
going on once everything ends for st.
Jude Children's Research Hospital and
you can help raise funds for that
awesome place on planet earth stay tuned
Children's Research Hospital this very
coming Super Bowl with the amazing
dinner that presents the Pat Summerall
award the legends for charity dinner
that's going on Thursday night at the
Super Bowl city honoring Jim Kelly all
in the name again of st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital and you join us for a
couple minutes once again the man who is
the president and CEO of al sac the
fundraising organization for st. Jude is
Richard che yeah how are you been sir
I've been great which sorry about
hearing about your dad my deepest
sympathies so know that please thank you
so how can we how can we all help you we
want to continue to sell tickets to our
event on January 30th at the
Intercontinental in Miami and we'd love
for you to support you rich Ison as you
do run Ritz Run and you know I want all
your listeners and and viewers to know
that you've raised over 1.2 million
dollars to support the kids at st. Jude
and I know you're gonna run that 40-yard
dash again this year I am and you're
gonna beat your personal best so those
are some of the things that go to our
website at st. Jude dialog that FTJ ude
org and you can learn more about our
mission yeah and then just again so
because people hear it for me I want
them to hear it from you who knows so
well from all of your years doing what
you've done when you do give money to
st. Jude whether it's through run rich
run or legends for charity comm to buy
tickets to see Jim Kelly on a big night
where Hannah storms the MC and Berman
gives them the award and James Brown
presents the invocation it's a big night
when when people do donate to Saints you
work where their money goes
so at st. Jude Children's Research
Hospital or specialty Children's
Hospital focus primarily on cancer and
the diseases of the blood we're not a
local Children's Hospital we are really
a Children's Hospital specialty
Children's Hospital listeners the entire
United States in the world so we see
kids that can't otherwise get treated at
their local children's hospitals a lot
of kids these kids that come here are
brain cancers bone cancers or what we
call orphan cancer so they occur very
very few times around the United States
in the world
but rich their money goes to help us
stay true to our foundational promise
that no family will ever receive a bill
from us not for the cost of treatment
travel housing or food because all we
want mom and dad to worry about is
helping their child survive cancer and
we're also a Research Hospital so you
know we do more research into pediatric
cancer than anybody else so we're
looking for cures at the very same time
that we're also taking care of kids with
our unsurpassed patient care I mean it's
heaven on earth Rick I mean with the
work that you and everybody else does
it's it's it's unbelievable it's it's
it's no place like it and and just in
the minute I have left here how how are
you doing in the fight here to to
eradicate this we've made remarkable
progress so you know we've taken overall
survival rates from 20% to 80% but that
still means one in five kids are gonna
pass away in the United States around
the globe especially in low and low and
middle-income countries
four and five kids are gonna pass away
in rich I know you know this but just so
your listeners I can say this we both
lost a dear friend you lost a dear
friend by the name of Austin who was an
aspiring sports broadcaster that you did
so much for and you know I want
everybody to know that one Austin was
you know toward the end of his life
we asked rich if he would send a video
that to cheer Austin up and and you did
that rich and I personally delivered
that to his bedside and he would just
come off a really difficult surgery and
if you could have seen the smiles that
you brought to his face and and also my
phone I went to a celebration of life in
Albuquerque and and you know you were a
big part of that celebration so thank
you for all you did to make his life
special but we can't let there be any
more Austin's rich that's right let it
happen
Rick love you love everybody there at
st. Jude and also al sac you're the
president and CEO again of the
fundraising organization that keeps st.
Jude Children's Research Hospital doing
the amazing work thanks for the call
Rick and I hope to see you soon right
back at you you bet st. Jude org is how
you can donate and you know run right
run will get that going soon legends for
charity comm to buy tickets for more of
the rich
in showtune - audience channel 239 on
directv for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app